ja herzlich willkommen zur heutigen
sitzung wir haben mark und ich haben uns
gedacht die heutige sitzung verwenden
wir darauf um die tagung der letzten
woche nach zu besprechen etwas darf ich
mal fragen wer von ihnen an dem workshop
oder der tagung teilgenommen hat einfach
mal kurz melden
okay das ist so die hälfte das ist gut
also nicht alle die hier sind waren da
das ist nicht schlimm wir wollen heute
darüber reden und auch sie mit
einbeziehen also ihre fragen die sich
noch im anschluss der tagung oder des
workshops ergeben hatten die wollen wir
heute alle behandeln und hier vorne auch
sammeln bevor wir dann in der nächsten
sitzung weitermachen aber heute können
wir auch nochmal auf peter von in
welchen zu sprechen kommen
und wenn ich möchte sie bei dieser
gelegenheit hier auf meinen
youtube-kanal nochmal verweisen also
viel okas dieses symbol hier die säule
und da finden sie hier
also eine neue rubrik und hier geht es
eben um diese ganzen vorträge und können
wir das ganze das ganze im groß machen
also es wird haben anders ist
[Musik]
wir müssen
als sie können sie hier alles
nachschauen das ist der erste vortrag
von peter pan in wegen dass es dieser
herr den wir in der letzten sitzung vor
zwei wochen diesem seminar besprochen
hatten
sein aufsatz und sie finden da natürlich
auch noch andere vorträge von ein
hausmann von mir von herrn buchheim von
weiteren referenten referenten können
sie alles auf diesem kanal nachsehen
ich denke das ist okay wir brauchen
jetzt nicht weiter anschauen und
deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen machen
wir das ganze aus hier und gehen mit
einer diskussion rein also vielleicht
fangen wir so anders wir mal sie fragen
was sie für eindrücke hat und fangen wir
doch mal so an dass sie für eindrücke
hatten was welche punkte
besonders aufgefallen sind ob es wo es
noch unklarheiten gibt wo sie noch
weitere punkte diskutieren möchten haben
sie da irgendwelche ideen dazu ganz frei
einmal assoziieren
wasser besonders interessant wo wollen
sie noch weitere punkte klären
ja
also denjenigen aus und was die kausal
beschlossen diesen leuten hier zu sein
genau das war der vortrag von professor
julian nida-rümelin das ist ein
professor den sie wahrscheinlich alles
schon mal gesehen haben hier
er hat den lehrstuhl für politische
philosophie
er hat einen vortrag gehalten über
gründe und freiheit naturata
journalismus und freiheit zu wahren
marco wie hast du diesen vortrag und
diese frage aufgenommen verstanden dass
man im prinzip der naturwissenschaft
muss insbesondere physik erklären und
die position nach dem beispiel gefragt
da steckt nicht mal vor wir wollen mit
dem auto hinfahren
das ziel mit dem autor ein jemand
und der grund brauchen wir an rechts und
links ist halt eben dieses ziel haben
und jetzt ist die frage in cannes der
physiker eben alles erklären
lässt irgendwie auch super artikel
irgendwie unseren berechnungen dann
bestimmte kausale und ziemlich
automatenhersteller wer kann lässt sich
nicht erklären warum ist auch bestellen
rechts oder links abbiegen und ein so
berühmtes prinzip das sind sozusagen
immer genannt wird das prinzip der
kursen geschlossen
das physische das ja dann auch zum
beispiel professorin würden seinen
vortrag thematisiert er also das prinzip
dass alle gute sachen einem
physikalischen eigenes musikalisches
oder anders gesagt es gibt keine
mentalen uhr sahen fern und sie kamen zu
sein ist also wenn ich jetzt mein arm
wird es ist ein physikalisches
ereignissen in der ober nach belieben
kann das schreiben und das prinzip der
geschlossenen des physischen besagt dass
alle ungesagt und 8 und sich meine am
montag selbst kann
jetzt ist die frage kann meine absicht
oder mein wunsch etwas bestimmtes zu tun
wenn es ein mentales sein es ist einfach
etwas im prinzip konzern geschaffen und
physischen das leben eines stars nicht
durch meinen wunsch oder meine absicht
überzeugung nach kant eben nicht aber
normalerweise schon
also könnte man das auch determinismus
nennen diese kausale geschlossenheit
oder ist es ist das prinzip das
determinismus zusammen ich schreib mal
hier drunter der termin ismus
es ist eine offene debatte ob das eine
zum anderen erfolgt oder nicht also für
den verein und das erlaubt mir kurz
einen blick voraus zu werfen oder
genauer gesagt zurückzuwerfen historisch
nämlich auf immanuel kant und weil du
jetzt gerade sagt ist es schließlich so
ein bisschen aus wenn alles kausal
geschlossen ist dass es dann auf anderen
gründen passieren kann ja und kant
immanuel kant wird eben die these
vertreten dass alles was sich ereignet
kausal geschlossen ist also nach diesem
prinzip des physikalischen der
physischen aber dennoch einen weiteren
grund haben kann wie zb unsere freie
entscheidungen wie zum beispiel ziele
zwecke und das dann kohärent zu denken
das ist die große herausforderung da
kommen da jetzt noch drauf
was geht so ein bisschen in die richtung
von karten nämlich über den begriff des
genau also hier gründe das ist ein
riesenthema
und er kann jetzt uns mal überlegen wie
wiederum in die gründe denken ja das ist
das spannend ja und was wolltest du
sagen noch dazu ja ich finde auch ich
finde die frage ist sehr berechtigt weil
es mir spaß so ein bisschen bei
diskussion über die frage ist also mir
aber auch nicht ganz klar wie ihr die
sachen zusammen denkt und da war ich
nicht der einzige
sie haben das auch gedanken natürlich
ich will mir den formalen hört weil das
immer so wenn man den ganzen tag sehen
wir nicht wirklichkeit ist sicher ob er
wirklich gesagt hat dass er mit grausame
geschlossen akzeptieren zitiert ist ja
also dann ist das wirklich ein problem
es gibt dieses berühmte argument form
shane kim
ganz privat momentan für unseren ist es
ist das stichwort und kommentiert dafür
dass das also dass wir nicht sagen wie
alt sind die kausale beschlossenes
britisches wir können alles restlos auf
diese karte zurück fühlt
darüber hinaus können wir aber doch von
solchen zahlen sprechen gegen die causa
er sagt es geht nicht dann hätten wir
eine förderung über die patienten und
das kann nicht sein also wenn wir alles
in allem eine physikalische jeanette
werden können dann können wir nicht
darüber hinaus wird die gründe
überzeugen unsere wünsche oder so an
sind sie dann auch besser also entweder
1 und wir sind also zurück
viel diskutiert und deshalb
schwierigkeiten darin zu sein
da ist dann die meldung aber
unwahrscheinlich dass technologie und
konnten endlich dass ich stan
wahrscheinlichen also alle klären konnte
st ich kann den laufenden unterhalt
gewichten dienst leisten
diese pauschale der usa des jüdischen
und eines physischen
ja das wäre ein so genanntes
systemisches argument und so wird auch
nida rümelin argumentieren wenn ich ihn
recht verstanden habt also sagt gründe
sind naturalistisch unter bestimmt also
wir können einfach epidemisch gründen ii
sie müssen gründe voraussetzen dass es
sie gibt lebensweltlich und wir können
sie aber nie naturalistisch angemessen
erklären dass wir dann erst eine
explorative systemischer zugang auf
diese sachen und nichts ist ein unter
logischer die frage die wir jetzt hatten
wir ja die ontologische fragestellung
wie sich eben gründe mit determinismus
vertragen gibt es praktisch die frage
ist die gibt es raum für gründe gründe
im sinne wie sie nida rümelin verstanden
hatte wenn alles determiniert ist in
diesem sinne physikalisch jetzt können
wir bei uns kurz mit dem begriff des
grundes befassen von ihnen wissen sie
noch wie er den grund definiert hatte
was sind gründe drei charakteristiken
hatte gegeben für gründe
das war nicht sehr interessant
erinnern sie sich noch also einmal war
es normativ normativ
wissen sie noch so ein punkt von den
gründen
sie waren auch ja ja genau also das kann
man auch hier noch mit rationalen das
ist sicherlich auch impliziert haben
noch einen weiteren punkt die es zu
dieser rationalität wie sehen sie denn
nicht man könnte sich jetzt eine
besondere rationalität vorstellen von
maschinen zum beispiel und die darüber
würde sagen maschinen können über keine
gründe verfügen warum nicht hat er so
ein argument das ist gegen die
künstliche intelligenz auch gericht ist
also künstliche intelligenz kann auch
wieder rumänien wenn ich ihnen recht
versteht nie mit gründen argumentieren
die gründe ins spiel bringen
bei gründe macht wiederum nicht
algorithmisch sind also nicht
algorithmische also nicht auf dieser
verfahrensweise passieren wie sie
computer haben genau genau
ganz ausdrücklich dessen 20 jahre davor
gegen die soll jetzt also gerade bei dem
thema digitalisierung künstliche
intelligenz besonders dafür wie opfer
dann mentale zustände weil das ist eine
neue form von mystifizierung wieder
aufkommt und das in ganz stark dagegen
und ich denke noch in dem interview mehr
unter dem hinweis alle symbole und genau
terminiert und gezeigt haben dass man
solche verfahren eben nicht genau wie
der üblichen zieht in diesem nicht
algorithmischen denken auch diesen
unvollständigkeit theorien von goethe
auch so war darin sieht er ein hinweis
darauf dass wir frei sind und auch dass
wir über kreativität verfügen also
kreativität lässt sie nicht algorithmus
ihren natürlich ist es jetzt her so ein
indirektes argument finde ich also damit
kann das nicht richtig beweisen kann es
ja nur irgendwie veranschaulichen oder
sagen gödels theorie liegt nahe dass
eben unser denken nicht determiniert ist
algorithmus irrt werden kann aber das
ist noch kein starker beweis er macht
das macht das leben scheint
so ehrte auch immer davon gesprochen
bestanden wir alles aus der physik wir
können alles restlos erklären
arbeitsplatz eine lücke das war also
dass ein gespann hier angesprochen wurde
also wenn wir alles restlos erklären
können physikalisch warum also bedeutet
es nicht bedeuten dass eigentlich kein
genauer die darüber würde vielleicht
sagen ja wir können alles erklären aber
nicht alles verstehen da gibt es diese
unterscheidung zwischen verstehen und
erklären verstehen es ihr das was mit
gründen zu tun hat und dann kommt eben
die klassische frage da musst du dann
einen dualismus ansätzen gibt es dann
zwei welten die welt des physikalischen
wo wir eben nur erklären können und die
welt des zins der gründe der raum der
gründe wie fritz ehlers sagt wohl alles
verstehen können aber wie existieren
raum der gründe und raum der ursachen
könnte man auch sagen wenn ursachen
dasjenige ist was den determinismus und
die kausale geschlossen hat auszeichnen
wie existiere koexistieren
die levels genau ist ist level also sind
diese levels oder diese bereiche der
ursachen bereiche der gründe sind die
koexistieren die oder sind die
ineinander von die jetzt in den
fundierung verhältnis man könnte ja
sagen irgendwie die sind in so einer
schicht als schicht verhältnis zu
verstehen so dass wir die selben
ereignisse einmal aus der perspektive
der gründen einmal aus der perspektive
der ursachen verstehen können also über
der termination wäre das stichwort und
immanuel kant denkt ist also eine freie
handlung kann eben vollständig
beschrieben werden was die vorgänger
anbelangt durch die naturgesetze als
auch eben durch und sind freien willen
das erkannt über determination aber das
ist natürlich wieder sehr voraussetzung
reich da muss man bestimmte dinge noch
voraussetzen jetzt hatten sie sich
gemeldet werden und sie hatte ich auch
nicht vergessen sie haben sich am
nachthimmel
ok
die regierungen
und genau da noch dieser generale
stunden guten werden kann darunter
festgestellt
also
es ist eine beziehung bestehen gewisse
weise über diese analogie zur schönheit
auch in diesem fall spielt er recht
[Musik]
ja also ich heute bekannt gibt es ja
einerseits dieses sehr moralisch
kommentierte freiheit die eben schon
nach kann wirklich auf scheint könnte
man sagen nämlich durch das wie er es
nennt faktum der vernunft also immer
auch wirklich faktisch also kann zeigt
ja also das sittengesetz unsere
moralität die macht sich wirklich fast
schon emotional bemerkbar durch das
moralische gefühl der achtung also
moralität ist verkannt ganz eng mit
seiner normativität verbunden die
wiederum auf freiheit verweist das war
auch meine rückfrage an der römer hin
wie er denn normativität hier verstehen
ob das jetzt moralisch ist und wir
moralisches handeln aus gründen erklären
kann wenn es normativ und rationales da
gibt es meiner ansicht nach auch noch
viel zu erklären
aber das ist vielleicht für zweite aber
also jedenfalls war worauf sie hinweisen
ist sie auch ein wichtiger punkt dass
wir freiheit nicht nur als moralische
glück nah dass wir sagen freiheit ist
nicht nur jetzt in diesem normativen
sinne zu verstehen sind freiheit
betrifft unsere gesamten lebens vollzüge
freiheit kann auch den bereich des
ästhetischen betreffen und dann ich
würde schon sagen dass er im
ästhetischen der gewisse normativität im
spiel ist aber es ist eben ein weiterer
sind von normativität
sie erinnern sich vielleicht noch an
einen beitrag von frau friede dorothea
friede die hatte auch einen vortrag
gehalten bei aristoteles ich schreibe
und die meinte eben zu dieser frage das
geben sie meinte ich sehe dass ein
bisschen skeptisch dass ben kang von
freien spiel der einbildungskraft
spricht nämlich von freiheit spricht
sondern frei nur als eine qualifikation
als ein attribut verwendet der
einbildungskraft ob und da bin ich auch
nicht ganz sicher ob man das so abtun
kann also man kann natürlich frei auch
einem schwächeren sinne verstehen im
sinne einer harmonie die vermögen
befinden sich im gleichgewicht und sind
ungezwungen und es läuft einfach so das
kann auch frei nennen aber ich glaube
dadurch dass kant ein begriff der
urteilskraft hat der auch ein vermögen
ist der urteilskraft ist ein vermögen
nach kant können wir durchaus stärkeren
begriff von freiheit ansetzen weil es
auch ein vermögen bezogen ist
ja genau
ja und deswegen glaube ich dass man also
durchaus auch von stärkeren brief von
freiheit bike ansprechen kann mit blick
auf die ästhetik also dass da stimme ich
ihnen zu
ja also das war also der punkt die
gründe und dabei die das ist sein
wichtig riesen punkt hat die gründe
nicht natural easy ride von gründen weil
sie normativ rational und nicht
algorithmisch sind vielleicht habe ich
sogar noch ein anderes attribute
vergessen gehabt vielleicht hätte noch
einen vierten punkt
er hat ein paar genannt bei gründen wir
die zu verstehen sind
haben sie noch weitere punkte die ihnen
aufgefallen waren auf der tagung
vielleicht was von in vagen anbelangt
sein workshop oder sein vortrag oder
andere vorträge hat sie können sich das
gerne alles nachschauen den vortrag von
herrn wiederum muss ich erst noch
schneiden den muss ich erst noch drauf
stellen dann habe ich noch gar nicht
fertig falls von ihnen jetzt erstmal
nichts mehr da ist markus sagst du noch
ein bisschen was zu verbergen wie du ihn
so erlebt hat ist sein vortrag oder die
wichtigsten punkte also noch nicht
publiziert sollen und können
das kann man auch noch mal hin schreiben
sollen und können vielleicht problem
und so war dann auch um dieses thema die
bundles für dieses problem also das
problem ist eben niemand handlungen
vollzogen
die sammlung ist entweder determiniert
oder nicht determiniert
wenn sie nicht determiniert ist dann
gibt es eben beim schein sie eben
zufällig zu sagen das heißt derjenige
der die handlung vollzogen 8 konnte
nicht anders haben lassen kann und wenn
sie ihr können hier ist das scheint
forderungen festival zu sein und die
rede gewesen konnte genauso wenig anders
an als er geld hat
das heißt jede handlung ist aber
entwickelte terminiert oder nicht
determiniert also scheint da was zur
folge dass niemand anders handeln konnte
er als der tatsächlich gehandelt hat
jetzt gibt es bestimmte moralische
vorhaben ich liebe absage das hätte es
aber nicht machen sorgen er hat mich
angelogen
den vorteil zu verschaffen gezeigt dass
jetzt uns auch nicht machen sollen dann
scheint es simplicio dass das nicht
machen können
wenn aber dieses generelle argument das
übernehmen wollen bereitet stimmen ist
dann heißt das wir immer dann mit mir
jemand sagen das hättest du nicht machen
sollte dass etwas falsches sagen warum
sie sagen etwas kompliziert dass er eine
ente man kann endlich getan hat das ist
immer falsch und das hat eine ganz
wichtige prämisse inter spielen wenn das
vermisse das soll also wenn jemand eine
person nicht hätte machen sollen
dann folgt daraus dass uns nicht mehr
machen können deswegen dieser vortrag
das auto im kern und wasserdampf geben
gemacht also letzten zwei drittel ist er
auf eine aktuelle und eine art
erschienene studie verwiesen
es sind so ein ganz neuer trend dafür so
viele selber experimente philosophie
oder 62 und das heißt dass man ebenso
leute das sind personen dass man
bestimmte fragen stellt und dann
geschaut wie sie was für konzepte was
für
die begriffe was wir begriffs
zusammenhänge die menschen auf der
straße ebenso haben und daneben steht
ist auch die philosophie zu machen hier
ist die zentrale messe solle initiiert
könne also wenn ich jetzt sage ich mal
es habe so sollen dann können und um
getreten wenn ich etwas nicht kann also
nur dann nun also wenn ich etwas nicht
kann wenn es mir nicht in meinem willen
steht wenn ich nicht die freiheit dazu
habe wir haben ja gesehen im letzten
absatz von von wegen das eben im können
ganz stark mit diesen metaphysischen
begriff von freiheit verbunden ist also
wahrscheinlich willensfreiheit also wenn
ich eben nicht willens frei bin sagt
jetzt mal grob dann kann mich auch gar
kein moralisches gebot er gehen
das impliziert ja dass ich frei bin
jetzt endlich erfolg haben wenn diese
these stimmt das moralische gewissen
also niemand hätte etwas tun sollte das
eigentlich getankt oder etwas
unterlassen sollen was er nicht
unterlassen
also wenn jemand schwer ist schweres
verbrechen begeht bringt ein brutaler
mord begeht dann würden wir sagen wir
etwas nicht machen sollen aber das ist
falsch ist also mein stück weil es dann
gar nicht hätte machen
oder gar nicht runter lassen können und
wie wir wissen sagen familienwagen die
sinnfreie wir können auch anders handeln
als wir anderen aber das ist ein
geheimnis
er kann ich erklären wie es sein müsste
terry ahn ist musste er muss ist dass er
jetzt eben gemacht habe es eine
möglichkeit aus diesen ganze dilemma
auszubrechen
es gibt viele möglichkeiten erste bilder
zu machen wir können frei sein obwohl
mitglied mbit/s ist die komplette liste
lösung der kommunistisch aus es gibt
keinen anderen ausweg mit können sagen
können zweiter obwohl unsere handel und
nicht das wäre ein anderer ausweg und
eine dritte aus erklärte zusagen sollen
im prinzip nicht können und es ist hart
obwohl das gar nicht obwohl er gar nicht
anders hätte können
es ist auch schon mal alle drei
möglichkeiten hin vielleicht ja also die
erste ist also nun im klammer auf wenn
es dann kann all das wäre es die
negation von dem da könnte man nun also
die erste ist bisher drauf drücken
das wäre die negation genommen wenn also
stimmt nicht versorgen können
die zweite zu sagen
[Musik]
3 und die hatten wir in den letzten text
behandelt die 2 schreibst du noch mal
hierhin determinismus und in
determinismus noch mal daneben
diese dass der termin ismus falsch ist
und dass er kompatibel ist mit
kompatibel ist mit freiheit zurück
man könnte sagen dass die determinismus
these sozusagen und dass die interviews
muss these die argumente dass das
determinismus oder in determinismus
unverträglich mit freiheit oder mit dem
können sein
also man muss jetzt hier irgendwo
ansetzen und sagen was jetzt hier nicht
mehr stimmten
[Musik]
das ist falsch eingeben könne also dafür
bin ich anders an den köln kann es schon
mal sein dass wir sagen können auch
imstande sein ziel
wir sagen dazu nichts sagen
also von dem wir hatten sehr stark
riechen können
es gibt ja auch der wimm bill dann also
wir müssen im stande sein wir mussten
die fähigkeit haben wir müssen auch die
gelegenheit haben in der richtigen
verfassung
[Musik]
aber es ist natürlich sehr wichtiger
punkt richtig versteht noch nicht genau
was ich sagen wollte ist gab er diese
untersuchungen scheinbar gezeigt haben
was bestimmte also dass wenn wir leute
befragen
in bestimmten situationen in denen
jemand nicht kann aber trotzdem das
hätte führen sollen und dass endlich
kommen konnte und da haben irgendwie 60
prozent oder so wir befragten trotzdem
noch schulz und gewesen obwohl das ist
doch aber eigentlich dann auch hier
dieses frankfurt php sie erinnern sich
wir hatten das war der zweite text von
harry frankfurt er hatte gesagt selbst
wenn wir nicht anders können könnten
könnten wir denn noch moralisch
verantwortlich sein für die handlung
weil eben das nicht können nicht der
grund ist dafür dass wir so gehandelt
haben sondern weil wir eben über
determiniert waren und schon im
vorhinein uns entschieden hatten für
eine option
und deswegen die fehlende alternative
gar nicht unsere entscheidung
beeinflusst letztendlich
vor allem welche die gleiche helligkeit
geführt angesetzt haben schon machen
zwischen unseren auch in diese richtung
einschlagen philosophie stallungen und
womit sie von innen beschäftigt hat war
mir diese psychologische versuchsaufbau
die ergebnisse jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen welche aussagekraft hat
so eine umfrage zu untermenschen was
würden sie sagen wenn jetzt die wenn
jetzt wie viel prozent auch immer dieses
jahr infiziert können in frage stellen
oder impliziert implizit denken wir
nicht akzeptieren
ganz kurz noch ein guter punkt
ich denke auch dass man skeptisch sein
muss weil es gibt zum beispiel häufig
intuitiv erscheinende fehlschlüsse zb
praktisch wenn es dann kam als will
sollen wenn aus sollen können folgt dann
folgt aus können auch sollen ja dass man
sagt dann macht man dass die negation
weg das ist auch häufig so in der logik
dass das leuchtet ein wenn gilt aber
wenn a und b
dann folgte aus dem bda ist aber nicht
und da müssen wir auch eine umfrage
gemacht das gibt es ja auch bei
logischen prinzipien ganz allgemein wo
man leute einfach eine umfrage stellt
und dann sagt was folgt jetzt und da
wird man sehen dass da auch man bei
manchen prinzipien viele einfach aufs
glatteis geführt werden deswegen würde
ich auch sagen ist dieses ist so eine
umfrage höchst problematisch
bekannte versuchen wurde schon nach gibt
den denjenigen der gegen keime und
annette theorie gelernt hat dass man
sehr schnell aufs glatteis führen kann
und das standgeld auf hamburgs ist wo es
seit gut und so eigentlich hat von dem
langen auch argumentiert auch zum
beispiel aus der not gebracht wo
eigentlich viele sagen würden weil sich
auf die intuition berufen
das ist so und so aber das wäre fatal
wenn es nämlich wirklich sohn zu werden
und ich hatte auch den eindruck dass
eigentlich keiner unter den zuhörern
also von denen diese gemeldet
die diskussion auch wegen anderer
michael vereinbaren also das ist denke
ich es war
jetzt hatte da war noch mehr drin
bei den kosten
aber wir sind frei
damit es sagen würde das nicht auf
inklusion ist bestimmt ich würde einfach
sagen na ja wenigstens in der
philosophie können wir uns nicht selbst
am schopf packen sowie münchen aus und
außerdem zum sie ziehen sein wir müssen
der welt geworden sagen bei
irgendwelchen dingen die uns
offensichtlich scheine und dem wir auch
ein längerer prüfung irgendwie nicht zum
einsturz gebracht haben und das sind ja
so ein bisschen so die ausgangspunkte wo
hast du in so vielen dass diese handlung
offensichtlich erscheint uns alles
andere
und eine dieser sache ist und da gebe
ich dir recht also ich könnte genauso
wenig die sache in frage stellt und sie
auch einen verstand allerdings seien ist
sozusagen ein jemand ist schuld daran
dass sechs über sechs millionen
hier in deutschland
achtung der würde sagen also das ist
eine werden müssen sie aufgeben
und da würde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
geben und die frage ist er natürlich als
philosoph muss sich da natürlich wenig
gegenargument bestellung und das macht
er und gibt der nur zum dass die
gegenargumente so stark sind dass er
selbst auch nicht den fehler zu finden
aber er ist trotzdem sollte es irgendwo
und so ist es ja auch so wir versuchen
bestimmte fehler zu finden über momente
gut formulierte wurden und also prinz
sie gibt es eine widerrede
meine jungen einfach gewinnen und
vielleicht haben
beim essen
machte auch nicht mehr weil in einem
neuesten paper hat er ja wie manche
wissen geschrieben nicht mehr freie
wille sondern erst dachte ich als er so
was schreibt erst als ich nur dass jetzt
da dachte ich das ist jetzt was ist das
jetzt aber dann kam ich noch so war es
dazu und dann war es klar weil sich nur
dieses ephla sagtest du liebe güte würde
jetzt ordinär vielleicht noch eine
eigene kurzem punkte ich hab's nicht
übersehen
mein vorschlag wäre freiheit nicht als
ein grundbegriff anzusehen sind als die
bedingungen die möglichkeit also
transzendentale zu behandeln also dass
man also weder intuition also freiheit
ist weder eine intuition noch ein grund
begriff sondern es ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit um verschiedene komplexe
andere themen in ihrem zusammenhang
überhaupt verstehen zu koennen also das
heißt wenn wir auf freiheit verzichten
können wir das nicht mehr erklären da
sind das und das und das und das nicht
und wir wollen diese dinge aber wir
können sie nicht besser erklären also
müssen wir freiheit voraussetzen dass
wir auch eine idee südrand des meintest
du vielleicht auch noch bis aber ich
würde sagen transzendentale würdigsten
einfach dem zusammenhang wenn wir den
begriff freiheit aufgeben dann verlieren
wir die kohärente möglichkeit die
möglichkeit andere phänomene corinne zu
erklären also wir wollen kein bisschen
denn sie ist ein anderer wichtiger punkt
nicht ganz überzeugt dass man freiheit
in diesem sind auch dabei ja klar
und das natürlich sagen es gibt
natürlich die position dass man zwei gar
nicht braucht und moralische
verantwortung ja sozusagen dagegen
argumentiert verbunden waren
und da hat er diese anderen durch 40
berufen und so ein bisschen also bis
reichenden ausschnitt von dem was sie
dazu sagen
was sehr leid
ich habe nicht gesehen dass wir heute im
volk überhaupt voraussetzt die
listenpreise also dass es überhaupt
polizei
aber wir könnten
in gewisser weise auch voraus heißt also
überhaupt nicht verstehen was haben
einen demokratischen gegenteil also auch
die novelle vielleicht über definiert
ist köchin haben immer noch unsere
da hat es ja nun deutlich geredet
erstmal da haben sie völlig recht hat
ein bisschen genuschelt und deswegen
haben wir ihm aber auch vorher schon so
ein mikrofon her dem gesetz und jetzt
können sie im wunderbaren noch einmal
nachhören auf die lowcost aber jetzt zum
anderen punkt was sagst du zu dem
postulat charta der freiheit könnte man
sagen das ist könnte man sagen müsste
realismus in die postulaten lehre der
freiheit das ist ein postulat ja also
ist es ist würde sagen es ist so eine
art vielleicht auch eine vernunft idee
also muss unsere vernunft muss die nach
nach von in welden muss also müssen wir
aus rationalen gründen freiheit
einsetzen oder würde was würde und er
würde wahrscheinlich auch gegen kann
sagen bekannt ist das postulat eine
sache der vernunft von ihnen wegen würde
sagen es ist keine sache der vernunft
sein es ist gerade mysterien ish also
nicht rational irgendwie zu erklären
das wäre zu sagen transzendentale dann
würde ich auch sagt transport zum
workshop ja da haben sie ein bisschen
gefragt mich hat interessiert im
workshop
ob es innere handlungen gibt also weil
man ja häufig die these hört dass es
wenn es um handlungen geht dann sind es
immer so äußere dinge zu brasiliens
sowas oder effizienz kausale ereignisse
also will gesetzliche sachen mich
interessiert eben stark vor dem
hintergrund meines neuesten buches über
das thema gründe des bösen interessiert
mich die frage ob es eben auch innere
handlungen gibt die nicht effizienz
kausal als im cdu es der wirt wirkung
auswirkung zu verstehen sind
und hat er interessanterweise gesagt ja
es gibt also innere handlungen hatte
gesagt ja da gab es diesen punkt der slv
actions also selbst form ihren
handlungen das ist robert kam auf den
wir ja auch noch ein gehen vielleicht
glaube ich sogar nächsten sitzung robert
k das ist ein wichtiger den schreibe ich
gerade an ja
ein wichtiger denke ja
[Musik]
zum beispiel indem ich meinen willen
form indem ich bei harry frankfurt ist
es so ich habe verschiedene designs auf
der ersten ebene und dann da sich
darüber reflektieren und meinen willen
selbst aktiv gestaltet dass ich manche
optionen ausschließen dass ich zb im
gedanken mir bestimmte szenarien
überlege und dann im gedanken auf eine
lösung komme also solche ihn also ich
denke einfach wenn es zum beispiel diese
first und second orte die sei es wenn es
darum geht das ist alles im will und
selbst enthalten und zum beispiel sagt
harry frankfurt einem anderen aufsatz
wir müssen auf basis der first oder
dieses unseren willen formen sagt wir
müssen in form vor also wirklich fashion
sagte uns nicht also bilden aus diesen
diesen erst ort auf erst das der ordnung
gegebenen wünschen und das ist ja noch
alles im villen drin das ist ja noch
überhaupt keine handlung nach außen
erfolgt also einfach wo reflexion in
besonders hohem grad vorhanden ist oder
ein anderes beispiel bei immanuel kant
immanuel kants sagt wir müssen uns an
willen wir müssen unsere maxime so
bestimmen dass sie dem kategorischen
imperativ konform sind
das heißt ich muss den dritten gesetz
den kategorischen imperativ anwenden auf
meine maxime und diese anwendung ist sie
eine handlung nicht wo es anwenden und
ich kann auch in der anwendung scheitern
ich kann zum beispiel mich selbst
belügen und wir selbst was vormachen
das bezieht sich aber alles noch auf den
willen und die handlung selbst die
physikalische handlung ist damit noch
gar nicht betroffen und in amerika gut
ist allein ein guter wille die handlung
ist nicht eigentlich gut zu werden
und deswegen muss man ja fragen was wird
da dem subjekt vorgeworfen wenn es böse
handelt würde ich kann zu lesen das kann
dann würde die innere handlung die
misslungen ist wir haben den
kategorischen imperativ mich richtig
angewendet und zwar nicht aufgrund eines
defizits weil wir zu blöd sind sondern
weil wir uns letztendlich selbst
getäuscht haben und täuschen wollte
wegen einer aktiven selbst täuschen
da gibt es aber andere these nicht sagen
nein das geht nicht weil was ist das
problem einer inneren handlung man
könnte immer wieder höhere instanzen
ansätzen es gibt das auch regress
problem was ist denn die letztendliche
instanz die den willen bildet das ist
dann wie bei frankfurt dieses problem
der höheren überhören ordnung wir finden
letztendlich keine letzte instanz wenn
wir ins innere gehen weil wir könnten
immer noch von höheren stufe aus den
willen formen während wir hingegen von
einer nach außen hin handelns im
substanz ausgeht dann sind wir es
einfach als als substanz als
körperliches individuum die die letzte
instanz sind also da gibt es
verschiedene probleme auf das hat auch
herr karl gutes hingewiesen in diesem
workshop sammer hat sich einige male ist
sehen sie hier
veränderungen der letzten beiden jahre
nicht verändert
eine studie über organisationen
ja also das führt dann wieder zu dieser
mentalen verursachung natürlich auch es
gibt wohl auch kausal kräfte die vom
denken ausgehen also unser denken unser
wille selbst keine kausale kraft haben
mentale verursachung und innere
handlungen lassen sich sicherlich auch
neuronal beschreiben also im sinne nicht
ihrer ursprünglichen qualität aber
natürlich kann die weise wie ich innere
handlungen durchführen wie ich denke wie
ich mich kondition ihre dazu führen dass
es physikalische änderung physikalisch
beschreibbare oder neuronal beschreibt
verwendung gibt ist es ganz klar also
eine innere handlung kann sicherlich
auswirkungen auf das gehirn haben ganz
klar aber eben die die gehirnstruktur
ist nicht identisch mit der inneren
handlung sondern sie ist eher eine folge
oder sie seien ausdruck der inneren
handlung aber sie darf nicht
gleichgesetzt werden
also ich würde eben nicht sagen dass
bestimmte struktur eines neuronalen
netzes identisch mit einer inneren
handlung ist das ist also die multiple
realisierbarkeit dann auch solche fragen
das wäre dann wieder das problem hier
von gründen und determinismus aber
sicherlich wie so wie wir denken um so
gestaltet sich auch unser gehirn
irgendwann und zu ändern sich auch
äußere physikalische eigenschaften ganz
klar wir sind eben nicht identisch mit
mit der inneren handeln würde ich sagen
ja
auf die moral stimmt
der schädel zu finden recht was also
immer wieder stellte brauche ich etwas
was machen diese regelhaftigkeit und wer
wurde und dessen funktion und david 3
ja also sicher nicht genau als auch so
was wie die reflektierende urteilskraft
[Musik]
ja also zu solche alle alle solche
vermögen die kannte ja sehr ausdrücklich
reflektiert die reflektierende
urteilskraft sie haben das mit der
obduktion verbindung gebracht dass sie
also ein gesetz postulieren letztendlich
oder auf eingesetzt kommen was so gar
nicht gibt und dann da etwas darunter
subsumieren das ist ja reflektierend
urteilskraft oder adoption auch
letztendlich das war also von einem
gesetz etwas reduzieren
das eigentlich so gar nicht in der welt
existiert sind dass wir jetzt mal
annehmen und dann merken hoppla
wenn wir jetzt annehmen und davon
reduzieren bekommen wie empirisch sehr
brauchbare ergebnisse heraus das wäre
sicherlich auch so ein fall von in der
inneren handlungs und gesetz anzunehmen
ist man würde ich auch sein
es ist ein spannendes thema innere
handlungen das interessiert mich
persönlich ganz arg und dann kann man
das mit mentaler verursachen verbindung
bringen kann zum beispiel fragen auf auf
welcher basis mit welcher art von
kausalität folgt eine innere handlung
sicherlich nicht eben der kausalität der
dieser causa eine geschlossenheit des
physikalischen glaube ich nicht es muss
eine besondere form von kausalität
zahlen kann man sagen dieses mentale
verursachung immanuel kant spricht von
einer kausalität aus freiheit die neben
der natur kausalität existiert das ist
dann die qualität aus freiheit sind
jetzt endlich die gründe das ist der
bereich der gründe der raum gegründet
dann muss man sich heute fragen wir
hängen sie mit zusammen konstituieren
sie zwei voneinander unabhängige welten
das wollen wir nicht dann haben wir
unser prinzip der ontologischen
sparsamkeit verletzt also hängen jede
menge folgeprobleme mit zusammen haben
wir sonst noch jemand übersehen
so fand in welchen er war auch sehr
gesprächig relativ jedenfalls
sozusagen sind es seine art ist ja dass
wir gar nicht so frei seien ich nenne es
ist auch sehr schön mit dem workshop aus
dem komma ist als sicher selber ordnung
wird schon das alles tut damit zeit und
man hat die paare leben sehr schönen
dank gesehen auf dem vortrag und moment
reagiert und überall wird man sich
verliebt hat
insofern hat ja nicht gesagt dass wir
über scheinen und bestimmten situationen
unseres lebens nehmen wirklich
entscheidend helfen unseren charakter
vor
und das ist dann wahrscheinlich sehr oft
so mit unserem leben das so genannte in
bestimmten situationen einfach so
reagieren wie es geben unseren charakter
vor schneit es und das in diesen
situationen wie vielleicht gar nichts
weiß aber dass wir trotzdem monat
verantwortlich sein und womöglich
irgendwann mal unseren charakter geformt
haben weiß ja was er da von leistungen
gebracht hat
während dieser form von hilfe dabei
wirklich
wenn ich jetzt eben ein kind wäre es
wenn ich jetzt frei zu entscheiden hatte
eine katze zu treten
nervt oder so ist es wahrscheinlich
einlassungen eine handlung die mein
charakter kommt also ist nächste mal
wenn ich in einer ähnlichen situation
katzenberg mich dann ist es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass wir schon so ne da
kann man sich vorstellen dass werde
schritt für schritt und mein charakter
wochen der manche sogar wahrscheinlich
ist ein großer und das im alter von 25
bis hatte gesagt genau richtig ist
werden wir dann in bestimmten
situationen eben dann einfach schon
geklärt haben darüber machen überlebt
hat und dann einfach unseren charakter
festgefroren haben ist es vielleicht so
dass wir einfach schon so reagieren mit
unseren charakter importe was nicht
heißt dass wir dann nicht mehr dass wir
da einfach sagen können also bin ich
halte ich kann nichts mehr dagegen tun
weil sie eben dafür verantwortlich sind
dass uns das leben in der vergangenheit
selbst geworben haben und erweitertem
was sagt dann ist das von altana
ich war vielleicht davor nicht
vielleicht habe man dann wenn bestimmte
positionen in der kommandos gestimmt
zwischen leben entscheidend zu spielen
die er auch persönlich etwas vom gelände
vereinigten staaten
und als die stimmung plötzlich rückt die
wenn man sollte ich jetzt die atombombe
abschließen würde ich ist es mehr
entscheidungen mit den vorjahren sind
sei es unser charakter in so einer
entscheidung nicht fest dass wir dann
immer noch neue schulden aber das war
nicht sehr interessant ist auch vielen
beispielen
dieses geld spaltung dass er irgendwann
ist es umgekehrt
aber er braucht erklärt und unter im
auge haben
machen diesmal ist es zum beispiel noch
hinein gegeben dass wir jedem geschoss
von den dingen im haus das wir haben vor
einer zweiten mal ja es ist noch eine
andere frage
ein super verlinkt dieser überträgt
also beide sachen das also war ein
tolles leben das in situationen in denen
uns in dem wir keinen moralischen
konflikt haben also den zweiten oder
dritten gekommen fliegt gibt zwischen
zwischen unseren wünschen einerseits von
dem was wäre eigentlich für das
vernünftigste halt nach situation wobei
das geld kommentierte wie ziemlich
wirklich haben wir nicht wirklich
entscheidungen zu treffen sondern das
ist würde ich glaube ich bin das beste
halte arzt tun wenn es wenn alle meine
wünsche ich überhaupt keine mannschaft
nichts zu tun
dann werdet ihr keine chance also sagt
reichen natürlich über die situation in
denen es irgendwie zu den kollegen kommt
also während wir uns wie sicher sind
dass es verpasst
diese option ist für den regelfall ist
die vernünftigste option ist aber unsere
wünsche bleibt nach wie vor einer
unserer engsten wir genau das passiert
das somit eine echte option und videos
entscheidend beeinflussen da auch die
acht unser charakter ist und der bereich
der beeinflusst wiederum jahr und weise
wie wir uns das nächste mal entscheiden
werden wir uns überhaupt
wenn
das wird
ja jedenfalls sind diese selbst
formierenden handlung sehr zentral und
das ist jetzt glaube ich ein gutes
stichwort um am ende wir hören hat ein
bisschen früher auf um am ende dieser
sitzung noch mal ein bisschen auf diesen
herrn hier vor blickend einzugehen den
werden wir jetzt seinen nächsten sitzung
auch der übernächsten sitzung aber der
nächsten sitzungen so eine sitzung also
dieser herr herbert kann der wird mit
einem bestimmten begriff in der regel in
verbindung gebracht wie sind sie das
nochmal wenn sie noch mal einen blick
auf dieses positionspapier werfen was
wir ihnen ausgeteilt haben welche
position innerhalb der drei heizplatte
vertritt robert k
genau markus schreibst du meinen ja hier
ist der stift ich habe ihnen doch sein
schreiben hier
die batterie muss die batterie und jetzt
haben wir hier wenn wir jetzt noch mal
hier auf diese drei prinzipien hier die
drei punkte hier eingehen
wie würde sich robert kennt dazu
verhalten zu determinismus in
determinismus und zuerst also dieses
problem das problem schon zusagen
behandlung wenn sie die termine sind
scheint ich frei sein zu können wenn sie
im termin sind scheint sich auch nicht
frei sein zu können und für die zeiten
im moralischen verantwortung also gibt
es keine moralische verantwortung und
kenntnis sehr gearbeitet aber nein ich
finde statt da muss dann würde sagen ja
soll kompliziert können wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere sehr verteidigend auch
also er wendet sich auch gegen er sagt
ja eine sammlung determiniert sind das
sind wenig frage aber würde sagen nein
wenn es wendet in die termine sind dann
können sie trotzdem fan sein und er ist
deswegen lieber tage
allerdings muss besteht aus zwei
gebäuden ersten säule ist die komplette
tourismus also wenn der vegetarismus war
es dann habe ich in unsere anderen
termin sind sie mir nicht alles riskiert
also das ja also genau also wenn wenn
sie das muss ja noch die passiert sind
dann können wir nicht anders handeln
[Musik]
offensichtlich frei also als er würde
das praktisch umsetzen bestellen daraus
würde voll also jetzt nimmt das mal
weggelassen das - wenn wir nur das haben
wenn der termin ist muss weiß dann
können wir nicht anders können wir
können aber anders als erfolgte aus der
city termin ismus falsche richtung aber
er sagt es gibt zwei probleme sind die
ersten teams bist du diese sicher der
sybil terrorismus falsches gemeint ist
ist er nach und offene wissenschaftliche
fragen die naturwissenschaftler auch so
ein bisschen ein physikalisches war ich
also kann eine echte wahl
kannst du daraus folgern dass bestimmte
müssen sich bewegen müssen die flächen
ziehen zur funktion ihres ersten und
david payne das hoffen sie fragen würde
sagen da musste physikalische phänomen
an die physikalischen thüringen die
gemeinsamen westen und dann hat einer
stunde theorie versorgung zu sehen wie
genau so wie es genau an unserem himmel
vorgehen kann dass unsere handlungen wie
terminiert sind für eine echte den
termin entscheiden also das problem geht
offensiv an und das zweite problem
wieder auch auf das sich an und das ist
ja das was von ihm wachsen stadtbad wenn
unter anderem in die termine sind
anscheinend sind anscheinend irgendwo
namentlich von unserer überlegungen
zusammen das heißt wir streben wir ein
produkt des zufalls zu sein
naja ich habe es meinen überlegungen
gemacht aber ich konnte trotzdem noch
aber man könne trotzdem auch nicht
abhaken also beides irgendwie vereinbar
mit meinen überlegungen deswegen scheint
deswegen bin ich an meinen überlegungen
zu hängen das nicht so hat das ist
dieses zufalls proben des vermietungen
machen
offensiv fand ich weiß dass auch
anschauen werden damit eben sagen ja
also da mussten wir den bus zwischen
verschiedenen arten von zu fall
unterscheiden und eine andere kategorie
design auch wenn sie in diesem sinne
also das wetter versuchen den staat zu
machen ist dass er mit seiner band am
meniskus war es dann ein wenig reifen
haben wir keine moralische verantwortung
aber wir haben offensichtlich eine
moralische verantwortung also sind wir
der minister
wie können wir aber frei sein
verantwortlich seien die tennis muss
falsch ist wir können und das versucht
er eben mit seinem mit einem bestimmten
modellen zu machen wir können auch dann
noch begründet haben wir also aus
gründen heraus halten wenn die handlung
selbst in die technik und es werde
dadurch sitzungsplan schon das ist nur
so groß genau und beteten
sofort ausziehen
das wissen zu verpassen
jakobus von und respektive
die forderung jetzt eine zufälligkeit
muss ist die heißen was die das dass die
das thematisiert und gesprochen also die
tatsache dass verschiedene optionen
vereinbart man überleben heißt jedoch
nicht dass die nach hinten zufällig dass
wir hatten beide in ihren handels und
vermindern hat eben dieses gedankenspiel
dass wir sagen klar stellung scoreboard
auf müde
wie werdet ihr wieder an einen zeitpunkt
zurückführen kurses vorführungen
handlung und schelmisch verdacht es 1000
machen also immer auf die reset taste
drücken wir kommen kurz vor zuhanden der
sagt wenn diese an
dann können sie manchmal so und zwar so
unterstellen wir zwei mehr macht es
tausende male
und dann können wir sagen dass man hier
auf 147 mal sowas wahlen 530 suchen
mussten
ist es dann nicht also ist es sei
natürlich plausibel zu sagen uns
zusammen und letztlich worden zufall
also können wir dann wirklich noch guten
gewissens bevor der diese haltung machen
versprechen was wir so handeln werden
wenn wir ein bisschen kann die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich sowieso
hatten ist eben nur bei 47 prozent
so wird so die frage gestellt und er
gibt selber zu dass es sehr effektiv
er hat da nicht so ein starkes argument
wie es im falle von den kommunisten ab
und das macht die sache natürlich auch
so ein bisschen fragwürdig ist er auch
nicht allzu überzeugt aber wir haben es
aber nicht geschafft unsere zeitung sie
wolle etwas sagt
bisher ist
und änderungen da habe ich mit dem
manager für einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
50 prozent sowie für mich wahrscheinlich
über seine stetig ausgeweitet und außen
zugeständnisse entscheidung also
vielleicht sondern ebenso viel recht
geben wenn es so ist dass wir im
falschen - ungefähr 150 prozent
wenn es so ist dann scheint es sich in
dem fall können wenig wirklich einfach
zu wenig wichtig wer des verfahrens in
dem ich im alter können auch ein
versprechen ab dem 13 dann sitzen sie
haben
die bevölkerung hat kein haus und nehmen
keine kann ich denke ich sollte mich
frage ist ist es wichtig sondern die
sache im internet ist das ist einfach
mittelfranken und kleingeräten ist es
nur die offene frage bleibt wie es ist
komisch aber was ich in der diskussion
versucht hat klar zu machen was auch mit
seinem vorteil ist
es ist vereinbart mit dem mini challenge
zu sagen es konnten eine relative
gewicht was alle anderen und zwar so
dass wenn wir jeden passiert ist so dass
jedes mal dieselbe beziehungsweise die
jetzt eine miteinanders und wenn es so
ist wahrscheinlich 100 prozent dann
schauen wir doch alle
das hat vor den wagen aber sehr infrage
gestellt ja das ist wollen wir noch aus
werden ist also eher scheint irgendwie
eine vorstellung zu haben dass im fall
von in den terrorismus
alle möglichkeiten gleichberechtigt sind
und da ist unendlich viele jeder für die
wahrscheinlichkeit von null zu haben das
hat er ja so workshop gesagt und da habe
man in der diskussion und setzt es
voraus dass alle wahrscheinlichkeiten
gleich gewichtet sind oder gebe es nicht
stimmt er hatte immer mit dem münzwurf
immer diesen münzwurf hat er immer als
beispiel gebracht
der auslöser könnte ich nicht der
meinung würde ich mein freund in
richtung der expansion höhere
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht im stich und
irgendwas wollen ja doch geschrieben und
das kann man vielleicht ist es dann
leicht moment entscheidungen oder
kontrollieren und mache
also guter punkt also könnte sagen ja
gut denn in der termin ist muss den
bringen wir immer wieder auf die
alternative zurück immer nur auf zwei
möglichkeiten
das reicht um dieses prinzip zu zeigen
ich kann ja jede handlung auf seine
alternative bringt das oder das und dann
habe ich 50 50 das ist ja dieses dieses
münzwurf beispiel kopf oder zahl 50 50
und wenn ich dann den fall hätte dass
das eine etwas bewegt wird das andere
dann wäre die frage ob es dann noch in
der termin ist ish genannt wird
das ist kein problem aber dann sind die
termine stream determinismus eben keine
konträren gegensätze das war so ein
bisschen punkt auf das ist und
determinismus heißt es gibt eine gruppe
ist und wenn er so definiert deshalb
offen gelassen zumindest begriffe ich
das vielleicht eine art
viele stellen nicht dass christian ohne
damit selbst genannt völlig in die
tennis fans
[Musik]
ja also prinzipien schwerkraft
organismus dann ist die sache anders
sein scheint dann könnte man wie wir auf
den anderen zug aufspringen und seien
gut aber dann ist die tebus entscheiden
und alternativen studenten vereinfacht
und jeder trinken wir es genau
definierten sich entweder für den
heimwerker stewardess unter anderem
geschrieben was sich dann noch gesagt
hatte war eben ist kann eben auch gründe
geben die nicht in einem notwendigen
zusagen die nicht hinreichende sind das
halte ich auch eine diskussion gesagt
so zum beispiel müsste ich dann genannt
hatte der fc soll ich nicht gesagt aber
so etwa also zum beispiel das sieht ja
immer verwendet ist fc bayern hat das
spiel verloren weil der schiedsrichter
eine fehlentscheidung gemacht hat und
das ist jetzt so also es gibt hiermit
die fehlentscheidung des schiedsrichters
wo es gibt etwas begründet ist also die
niederlagen von 16 bayern und es ist
aber nicht so dass aus der tatsache dass
der schiedsrichter eine fehlentscheidung
gemacht hat notwendig falls der fc
bayern mit
es ist natürlich möglich dass fc bayern
gewinnt obwohl er einen fehler gemacht
das ist auch schon vorgekommen aber was
heißt eigentlich das ist nicht einfach
zu finden sein kann dass den bayern ein
spiel verloren hatten
das bestätigt eine fehlentscheidung
getroffen hat und bisher ein beispiel
für einen grund wir aber nicht notwendig
zusammenhang kann es irgendwie gründe
bestehen und es wäre etwas was man dann
sagen alle gut vielleicht ist in der
terminus geben trotzdem für gründlichen
entscheidungen in diesem schwächeren
fahren kann trotzdem noch gründern und
warum es so und ich anders entschieden
habe die gründe sind eigentlich nicht
notwendig ist zu meiner entscheidung
aber sie so wie lange uns vielleicht
seien würden sie ihm trainieren also
investiert nicht das ist so dass man
entgegen und so weiter also kein zitiert
auch dass in diesem zusammenhang würde
das auch so denken würde sagen eine
gründete entscheidung sind möglich
selten ist so etwas in den terrorismus
und was von den beiden in einem workshop
gesagt dann haben wir auch sehr
interessant der würde er meint also wenn
es nicht wenn es in nicht in noten in
zusammenhang steht
dann würde jährlich
sondern das wäre dann weiß nicht wie wir
das genau gesagt hat das wäre dann
höchstens ein teil gesamt gut wenn jetzt
keine weiteren fragen mit da sind würden
wir heute ein bisschen früher aufhören
ihr fotografieren das abstellen auf fast
sie haben den link bekommen per e-mail
gestern von mir noch später zu später
stunde zum nach sind der videos es
werden weitere videos drauf gestellt von
der hellen baby wenn sie mir das okay
gibt dann noch vom die darüber liegen
und wer kommt noch drauf fritzsche
swinburne den hatten wir gar nicht jetzt
groß besprochen
da können wir das nächste mal mache so
schauen sie sich doch aufs nächste mal
erst mal den ersten 50 für die ersten 15
minuten nochmal sofern sie die zeiten
des interesse haben die videos an die
wir jetzt aufgestellt haben sie kommen
über den playlist link zum aktuellsten
videos swinburne ist auf dann auch baby
auch und machen sie nochmal notizen dazu
vielleicht vor allem swinburne sprechen
wir das noch mal kurz und dann kommen
wir auf diesen herrn hier entsprechende
robert kellner auf seinen liberta
realismus und vielleicht auch auf seine
sehr forming actions die mit diesem
termin ismus
zusammen dann bis zur nächsten sitzung